coming from countries like Bangladesh
are not being removed Bangladesh they
will go back they will go back to the
countries where people come from
K do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop allot of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course recommend
this
course to access the free lifechanging
training
now alayum brothers and sisters and dear
friends K stama the absolute joke the
absolute sellout a man who with no
morals you know as long as his Z his
friends are paying him he for some odd
reason we're not going for the
Palestinians but for this time he is
going for the Bangladesh Community very
oddly why I mean it's so bizarre I mean
what happened did your Cur get served
extra spicy you know did it have a fiery
exit what happened what's what's what's
caused you to go for the Bali Community
out of all communities the community
that is there are millions of them here
who were brought uh by your government
here uh subh who have served the UK and
uh in many many ways Subhan Allah the
Bangladesh Community have supported the
UK serve they work hard they're
hardworking individuals who support
their family Subhan Allah has given
great services to uh the UK but no he is
going to deport them back here is what
this guy had to say let's watch it for
ourselves in I could not believe my ears
when I saw the video of K stor
today attacking the Bangladeshi
Community not once but twice people
coming from countries like Bangladesh
are not being removed Bangladesh they
will go back they will go back to the
countries where people from he attacked
them by
name what did the bangladeshis
do other than loyally support labor
generation after generation only to see
themselves on TV being spoken about as
if they were illegal aliens arriving on
the
beach on the south
coast the Bengali is are the hardest
working people in Britain working till
2:00
1:00 2:00 in the morning they get home
the people in the kitchens waiting on
the
tables they've built a multibillion
pound industry in
Britain they've made more contribution
to the economy of
Britain head
forhead of any population in Britain and
then they're getting attacked people
coming from countries like Bangladesh
are not being removed as if the they
were some kind of dirt that we have to
sweep off our
doorstep gear starmer committed
political suicide with the so guys you
heard that for yourself I mean I'm going
I'm going to have to reply to him in
bangladesi Bali yes that's what I'm
going to do insh so I'm going to say you
know to
him okay that's right right you're a
waste man you're a useless man shut your
mouth yes you have to shut your
mouth don't make me angry shut your
mouth how dare you attack this amazing
Community this Bangladesh Community
aldah who's done so much for
alhamdulillah with their food with their
culture alhamdulillah they have done so
much and you are here saying that you
are going to send them back if there's
anyone that's need to send back it's you
we need to send you back yes yeah God
knows where your uh lineage comes from
yeah are you what a German why are you
where you from originally yeah let's
send you back he yes what do you offer
this country hey what do you offer this
country you can't even make curry mate
all right on your nights out on your
weekends when you finished what you do
yeah let's go have some Curry you don't
even have a culture you don't even have
a culture yourself and you are here
attacking the Bengali Community who have
done so much and offered so much and
your country has gone and literally
ransacked that country and many many
other countries around the world and
you're here trying to come and have this
high moral ground you are zero you're
bankrupt you're intellectually bankrupt
yes you are morally bankrupt you can't
even stick up for the Palestinians right
so it's not at a shock to come to us
that now after you do not defend the
Palestinians who have been massacred you
randomly attack the Bengali community so
brothers and sisters as you can see
alhamdulillah a special you know message
to our buali community as well you know
this the reason why your parents and our
parents I'm not from Bangladesh or
Kurdish Turkish but you know tell us to
build back home you know why because
it's a reality these people would kick
us out the very next day and that's
exactly what's happened it happened with
shim as you can see you know it's just a
double standard aldah and put all this
aside put all this aside okay if they're
coming for your culture today to your
from your background your race where
where you're from Imagine Subhan Allah
your religion okay these people don't
even like you for your color and what
you look like let alone your religion
that's what Allah says you know the
these people and the prophet Muhammad
said they will never be happy with you
until you live your religion yes step by
step you follow them until you say I am
not a Muslim anymore I am not a bongol
I'm a white you know these people who
have these uh you know coconuts yes
unless you say that they are not happy
with you so like I said before brothers
and
sisters shut your mouth K do not attack
the Bali Community aldah brothers and
sisters if you've enjoyed this video
please share it with your friends and
family I thought I just let you guys
know what kind of an absolute he
is I don't vote I'm not getting involved
in voting but if you are you definitely
know um another party you should not
vote for uh that's what I'm going to say
inallah may Allah bless you guys
inshallah till next time